[Music]
yes starting these hugely popular TV
series lost and her new movie the hobbit
the desolation of smaug opens December
13th please welcome the lovely and
talented Evangeline Lilly and I
compliment you on your Smaug my smell
yeah your smoke is so good you say it
very well a lot of people say small yes
it's the desolation of smaug doesn't
that make me more attractive to you all
of a sudden all of a sudden there was
nothing before knowledge is very safe
yeah knowledge is also don't you think
elvish is very sexy I'm gonna say so yes
because you're looking at Elvis you guys
you have to learn to speak elvish for
the role you play and I'm just curious
do you feel it's like a sexy language
yeah well yeah and it like it like like
sensual maybe more than sexy it's very
sensual you know there's like at the
tapped R which is the sensual Spanish
sound and then French vowels which how
sexy is it French can you can you give
me a little Elvis right now do you mind
oh ok so one thing I could say is here
than in Legolas and that would be my
lord Legolas but like even sexier
there's the word friend in elvish it's
Mel Mel C would you do it it's sexy when
I do it it just sounds like I've been
hit in the head yeah you're like you're
I think it's more you than the language
because I'm female in your mail I mean
it's sort of wrong when no real Purdy
try to be
you think men can't try to be sensual Oh
what really I'm talking about show up
women bring the sensuality no one ever
told me that I never know what told me
that I wish someone had told me that 40
years ago all this time I've been like
[Music]
Lela this was sexy what I'm doing right
now okay I don't I never thought this
was sex you just show up did you saw it
what showing up didn't work out either